joey boasts a third overall pick in the
2016 draft chris remember this he held
out deep into his rookie training camp
in pre-season
and i think that memory resonated for
the chargers because joey bose is a guy
who's not going to screw around entering
the final year of his contract has four
years in was due to make 14.36 million
this year in his option year the
chargers out of the blue
break the bank nobody even knew the
conversations were happening tom telesco
the gm downplayed any talk of player
contracts when he met with reporters on
monday and here it comes on tuesday
night five-year 135 million dollar
extension that's 27 million per year in
new money when you throw in the final
year of his rookie deal he's at almost
25 million per year from signing on a
six-year deal it is amazing when you
consider
he went 2 million per year over miles
garrett in new money he's left khalil
mack at 23 and aaron donald at 22.5 in
the dust and look one of the things that
makes this deal so good
is we still haven't seen joey bosa
fulfill his full potential yet
51 games out of 64. he's never had more
than 12 and a half sacks in any one
season he averages 0.78 sacks per game
which is very good
but he's across from melvin ingram
so i i i'm i'm saying you know that
they're paying for potential here not
for production not for what he's done
because there's plenty of guys who've
had 12 and a half sacks in a season and
they ain't getting 27 million per year
so i'm i'm i'm stunned by this
especially during the pandemic
and i really do think that the chargers
blinked hard because they knew in their
hearts joey boso was not going to show
up or maybe even was considering opting
out and being gone for the whole year
and saying i'll be back next year for my
14.36 million you can give me a contract
then well yeah i mean hey i mean there's
a lot to say here first off joey bosa is
definitely you know in that conversation
for one of the better defensive players
in football i mean he stop stop time out
time out yeah i like how you said that
yeah he's in the conversation for one of
the better defensive players in football
he's not in the conversation for the
best defensive player in football no
he's talking about the best defensive
players in football right nick is more
likely to come up than joey because
there's this nagging sense he's never
lived up to his potential chris whether
it's injuries or whatever so all of a
sudden he rockets to 27 million per year
that's what's astounding to me yes he's
great yes he's got the potential to be
great but 27 million per year i'll tell
you what i i just think that that that
that hold out from four years ago
freaked the chargers out well man they
decided wait we're gonna pay him now
we're gonna pay him later let's just go
ahead and write the check yeah write the
check first off you know but he's one of
their guys he's a top five pick he loves
football he works hard as hell so those
are the kind of guys organizations like
to reward right we know that just from
that standpoint and then hey listen yeah
i don't look at him as the best player
in football definitely no i don't but
yeah one of the better ones he's
certainly one of the best pass rushers
in the game i mean he is he's in that
convo hey i'll just for a little like
you know a little clarity here khalil
mack he was dancing around like 40 sacks
his first four years it was right around
there i didn't add up the math totally
there but it's something like that you
know so you take the guy like that who
got paid huge money you know joey bosa
yes he's been he's only played two full
seasons but he's a dominant force and
then i think what ad added to that mike
is just the fact that he's also the
perfect scheme fit you know again that's
the seattle defense that's why the 49ers
drafted nick bosa and got d ford you
know that's why seattle in their prime
had cliff averill and clemens off the
edge and guys like michael bennett and
all that so you know this is important
to the success of their overall scheme
too let alone he's a homegrown guy and
you know there's not a lot of guys out
there like him yeah i mean you know
maybe i wouldn't put him in the top two
three pass rushers in football but he's
right there outside of that he's in that
next group you know do i think he's as
talented as miles garrett no i don't but
you know
and this is what you and i talk about
all the time right why why does this
happen what is what is the deal with
this i don't think anybody should be
paid more than aaron donald if i was a
gm i'd go wait aaron donald makes this
he late let's look at the stats look oh
oh clearly he's the best defensive
player in football so why would anybody
command more than that that's where i
just i'm i'm always confused by that by
the owners and the gm's that they do
that and there's not more of a fight but
regardless this is the way well here's
the response yeah go ahead here's the
response aaron donald was two years ago
the market has changed the cap has
changed right in a normal year that
flies yeah what makes this more stunning
racing for unprecedented losses they're
bracing to play games without fans
present some would say the chargers
should be used to that but at least they
sell the tickets to the fans of the
visiting team
next year the salary cap is going to be
175 million so i i want to see the
structure i want to see the cash flow i
i always want to see the details but i
see enough so far to make me say wow
joey bose got a hell of a deal and maybe
the message to the guys who are
entering the nfl because we see so many
of these rookies they just sign their
contract sign the contract sign their
contract the agents don't necessarily
want to fight with the teams there isn't
a whole lot to negotiate about
maybe if you drive a hard bargain on the
way in it sets the stage for you to get
your second contract without a lot of
pain and suffering aaron donald held out
two training camps to get his eventually
khalil mack had to hold out and force a
trade from the raiders to get his all
joy bows had to do was show up for
training camp number five and there's
the deal so maybe there's some wisdom
you know if you're gonna go through a
tussle with a team first contract or
second contract yeah maybe you go
through with the first contract maybe it
helps you avoid it the second one yeah
well
yeah yes i you know again hey squeaky
wheel gets the oil in the nfl you know
the coaches they can they can claim all
they want all the time that like oh
you're you be good and you act like the
team player you know we'll reward you
blah blah blah blah blah blah those are
the guys they always crap on the team
players the guy they always the first
time somebody to blame they're like oh
i'll blame him because i know he won't
talk back to me okay and then the
squeaky wheel who's might have messed up
ten times in the game he doesn't get
anything said to him because they're
scared he might talk back but also i
think the chargers probably feel a
little like self-conscious they're the
ones that he held out in rookie minicamp
the contracts write themselves as you
always say and they were trying to like
put some stupid language in it that
didn't make sense
the bottom line is is it shocking yes
definitely but not it's not that
shocking is what i'm trying to say it's
a big number it's a lot of guaranteed
money but i think if you look at some of
the people that are big time talents in
football yeah i mean he's in the
conversation with miles garrett he's
better than demarcus lawrence through
four years it's not even close so you
know from you look at it from that angle
deforest buckner i know last year was
awesome but the first few years people
were wondering if he was worth the top
10 pick and things like that so you know
i i think from the standpoint of just
the overall nfl i understand bosa
getting this time type of contract i
guess i'm a little shocked that it blew
everybody out of the water to this
extent
very quickly yeah and you just have to
give me a yes or no or you pick one word
answers
joey bosa or miles garrett
miles garrett
joey bowser khalil mack
ooh that's a close one huh
i'd probably go
i'd go clear mac but it's close
joey beau sir aaron donald i'm going
aaron donald
joey bowser nick bosa oh
gosh
i yes i like nick bosa more yes i do i
do and then damn joe you're killing me i
like joey bosa a whole lot but yes yeah
those are especially trying to but
you're right trying to show what a good
deal he got from the la chargers uh
because but after that action has not
yet matched the potential i know
potential continues to be significant no
after those guys you're right
joey wins yes but that but but
27 million
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports